alors mes chers collègues
pour notre première audition en format
plénière et avant de recevoir tout à
l'heure les ministres nous entendons
aujourd'hui madame Laurence Rouet et
bienvenue madame la vice-présidente
présidente de la région
nouvelle-aquitaine en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire également
présidente de l'établissement public
foncier de nouvelles Aquitaine et donc
très au fait des questions qui nous
occupent dans cette commission spéciale
et c'est au nom de région de France
quelle intervient devant nous pour
présenter l'analyse des régions sur le
texte qui nous est soumis le 6 décembre
dernier la mission conjointe de contrôle
sur Lausanne avait déjà auditionné la
présidente de région de France madame
Carole Delga l'exercice est aujourd'hui
quelque peu différent puisque nous avons
depuis déposé une proposition de loi
sénatoriale sur le sujet du zen et
constitue une commission spéciale
chargée d'examin ce texte nous devrons
d'ici au 8 mars prochain présenter un
texte de commission
qui sera ensuite examinée en sciences
publiques le 14 mars il ne s'agit donc
plus de rédiger un texte en partant
d'une feuille blanche mais de recevoir
plus précisément l'analyse des régions
sur les dispositions du texte article
par article afin éventuellement d'y
apporter des ajustements
l'analyse de région de France est très
importante pour nous madame Rouen madame
la vice-présidente puisque les régions
sont au cœur de la mise en oeuvre
d'usane et de sa déclinaison dans les
territoires elles élaborent les schémas
régionaux d'aménagement de développement
durable et d'égalité des territoires les
stradettes qui fixeront les objectifs et
les répartiront entre territoires elles
auront aussi la possibilité de
mutualiser des projets d'intérêt
régional ou national la proposition de
loi sénatoriale comprend plusieurs
articles qui concernent directement les
régions
elle modifie par exemple le calendrier
d'évolution des stradettes ainsi que
leur rapport avec les documents
d'urbanisme locaux elle vise aussi à
trouver des modes de coopération et de
concertation entre différents niveaux de
collectivités territoriales proposant la
création d'une conférence régionale de
gouvernance d'usage elle prévoit enfin
au niveau régional de réserver une
partie de l'enveloppe au profit d'un
droit minimal zan d'un hectare au profit
de projets supracommunaux nous attendons
vos retours sur ces différents points et
surtout autre mesure du texte que vous
souhaiteriez aborder afin de vous
laisser la parole je la cède tout
d'abord au rapport avant de vous laisser
la parole pardon je la cède au
rapporteur mon collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc qui va vous adresser quelques
questions plus précises pour ayant
orienter nos échanges recueillir vos
analyses puis nous vous écouterons pour
une durée d'environ 20 minutes
avant de procéder à un échange
question-réponse avec nos collègues
membres de la commission spéciale j'en
ai terminé Jean-Baptiste monsieur le
rapporteur à vous la parole
merci merci madame la Présidente
Michel collègue madame la
vice-présidente vous avez un excellent
tableau cas ici avec Christian Redon
sarrasin sachez-le
oui ah voilà
Frédéric Espagne vous avez que des amis
voilà on a besoin de vous
on a besoin de vous pour nous éclairer
évidemment sur ce sujet
épineux du zan et dans le cas d'un
calendrier qui s'accélère fortement
souhaiterait vous poser quelques
questions sur le premier chapitre de
proposition de loi notamment intitulée
favoriser le dialogue territorial et
renforcer la gouvernance et centralisée
la loi climat est résilience a confié
aux régions le rôle prépondérant de chef
de fil dans cette architecture nouvelle
du zan et la première ministre et la
confirmière récemment à Marseille tel
que nous l'avions envisagé au Sénat et
dans la CMP il s'agissait pour la région
de donner des grandes orientations
déclinées par les collectivités
compétentes en matière d'urbanisme la
commune et le PCI mais les décrets
d'application ont profondément modifié
la nature du stradet comme chacun le
sait qui sera désormais une forme de
super spot régional
et on échangera je suppose là-dessus qui
fixe des objectifs contraignant pour les
collectivités et plus que contraignant
c'est ce que nous enfin on en parlera or
le stradet n'est pas un document
d'urbanisme sauf la preuve du contraire
il n'avait auparavant cette vocation
n'avait pas cette vocation et d'ailleurs
son élaboration n'offre pas les
garanties habituelles de concertation
que qui prévalent pour les scottes et ou
les pluies nous n'entendons pas remettre
la en cause la compétence à la région
naturellement mais il nous semble qu'il
faut rassurer les collectivités locales
et leur représentant ici par votre
conséquence pour apporter des garanties
de dialogue territoriales et renforcer
la proche décentralisée pour parler
gouvernance du zan en clair
pourriez-vous nous donner la position
des régions sur l'article 2 également du
texte qui vise à revenir à l'esprit de
la loi que nous avions voté en donnant
aux dispositions
et non de contraintes en clair nous ne
voulons pas de fascicule réglementaire
et c'est l'objet là d'un bras de fer
avec le gouvernement les régions sont
elles toutes favorables à ce que le sera
dette devienne un super Scott comme le
souhaite donc ce même gouvernement
comment les régions entendent-elles
s'emparer des propositions qui ont été
faites par les conférences et des
scottes en matière de territorialisation
notamment sur les critères de
répartition à venir est-ce qu'il vous
paraît de bonnes pratiques que les
régions sont tenues de justifier de la
manière dont il a été tenu compte de ses
propositions comme le prévoir l'article
2 si vous le permettez j'aimerais bien
savoir et je pense que la Commission
s'associera à mes propos comment ça
s'est passé de votre point de vue dans
votre propre région au sein des régions
si ça n'avait le retour se droite
proposition exercée par les scottes ces
propositions qui devaient être déposées
avant le 22 octobre cette conférence
était scottes et les décisions que doit
reprendre les régions avant la semaine
prochaine en l'état du texte si nous ne
montons pas autre chose et dans la
perspective de modifier votre réviser
plutôt un stradette comment vous avez
accueilli ces propositions ces demandes
de différenciation
et on échangera là-dessus si vous le
voulez bien quel est votre sentiment sur
la conférence régionales de gouvernance
que nous proposons par l'article 3 qui
rassemble la région les interco et
surtout les mers dans ce qui est à
présent une simple conférence des
scottes le ministre niveau que de la
complexité une énième usine à gaz voilà
des choses sympathiques comme ça mais
n'est-il pas nécessaire de mettre tout
le monde autour de la même table à un
moment donné pour aborder ces questions
quant au projet d'ampleur national et
européenne
sujet très important aussi de ce texte
prévu par l'article 4 la méthode de
qualification proposée c'est-à-dire par
les régions après avis de la conférence
est-ce que tout cela vous paraît adéquat
est-ce que tout ça vous paraît adéquat
d'avoir une gouvernance régionale qui
donne un avis sur qu'est-ce qu'un projet
d'intérêt national européen qu'est-ce
qu'un projet d'intérêt régional
et je n'oublie pas les petites communes
et la ruralité
et le littoral et sa montagne et puis
les deux comme chez Frédéric voilà nous
proposons deux choses d'abord une mise
en réserve d'une part d'une petite part
de l'enveloppe régionale en vue de
pouvoir autoriser des projets d'intérêt
supracommunal dans des petites communes
n'ayant pas à cette droite et d'autre
part proposant une surface minimale pour
toutes les communes à hauteur d'un
hectare qui fait beaucoup gloser afin
d'éviter que les communes peut
consommatrices ne soient sacrifiées je
veux dire autrement une petite commune
qui ne parle pas se faire entendre de
son de PCI de son Scott de sa région et
qui sont pas concernés par cette
histoire d'usane qui a l'impression de
subir cet objectif qui ne va bénéficier
au final toujours même c'est-à-dire les
métropoles des grands ensembles on
connaît le la chanson donc c'est pour ça
qu'on propose nous des filets de
sécurité
et en l'espèce donc cette surface
minimale cette enveloppe régionale
consacrée à la ruralité je crois que les
régions sont peu favorables à ces
mécaniques mais mécanismes car elles
craignent qu'ils n'ont plus de trop
fortement l'enveloppe régionale qui doit
être territorialisée pourriez-vous nous
préciser cela et nous présenter vos
propositions alternatives pour protéger
les communes rurales parce que nous
sommes sûrs
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
vice-présidente vous avez la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs merci merci
d'abord pour le principe de cette de
cette audition j'excuse évidemment
Carole Delga et puis alors où c'est qui
le président de la commission
aménagement de territoire qui suit
également de près ce sujet du stradette
et du zen en particulier et puis vous
remercier d'avoir créé à travers cette
opposition les conditions d'un débat qui
vient de façon convergente aussi
accompagner les régions mais aussi
d'autres les autres représentants des
collectivités locales dans des
discussions que nous avons depuis cette
loi depuis les décrets d'applications on
avait même discuté on était auditionné
région de France par le cabinet
d'Emmanuel vargon à l'époque avant
l'écriture des décrets d'applications il
y a un certain nombre de sujets que l'on
retrouve aujourd'hui et que l'on avait
déjà
pressenti et demander d'essayer d'éviter
bon on en a pas on n'a pas été
suffisamment entendu de ce point de vue
là on l'avait été un petit peu sur le
sur les délais donc merci évidemment de
nous
proposer à travers cette proposition de
loi la possibilité dans d'en discuter je
vais je vais répondre à vos questions et
vous brosser assez rapidement
les premières réactions et bien entendu
en complétera avec le questionnaire un
plus de façon plus complète parce qu'il
y a des sujets aussi sur lesquels on
aura besoin de concerter plus en
profondeur certaines autres régions mais
bien entendu je pourrais vous parler en
particulier de l'expérience de la de la
nouvelle Aquitaine donc vous dire en
effet que d'abord rappeler que les
régions on a pris nos responsabilités en
termes de sobriété foncière et la loi de
notre il y a un certain nombre de sujets
sur lesquels on a envie de se rapporter
aussi à la loi notre est-ce que la loi
notre avait prévu notamment sur les
stradettes et en particulier le fait que
les stadettes ne doivent pas être des
supersquots en effet nous sommes là pour
prévoir des schémas Régional
d'Aménagement de grandes présentation
nous ne sommes pas des documents de
stradettes ce n'est pas un document
d'urbanisme j'en fais la différence je
suis moi-même adjointe d'une commune de
25000 habitants étant adjointe à
l'urbanisme alors vous voyez je suis au
debout de la chaîne alimentaire du zan
de ce point de vue là donc bien sûr on
se rapporte beaucoup à l'esprit de la
loi notre et les régions on avait pris
nos responsabilités sur le sujet de la
sobriété foncière et il est vrai que on
s'est engagé parce que voilà on respecte
la loi donc on s'est engagé dans ce
timing de février 2024 sur deux sujets
qui sont extrêmement complexes et c'est
ça qui est difficile vous parler
monsieur le rapporteur de du maire rural
du maire un peu isolé qui découvre tout
d'un coup une masse de voilà de
réglementation et de sujets qui qui
peuvent l'inquiéter et on le conçoit
très bien et toutes les régions l'ont
très bien entendu et conçus qui est
effectivement c'est très complexe c'est
d'autant plus complexe que l'on compte
la consommation jusqu'en 2031 et le
passage aux ânes jusqu'en 20551 ce qui
n'est pas la même façon de penser
d'imaginer les choses donc de ce point
de vue là tout ce la proposition de loi
pour venir faciliter la coordination
entre consommation et artificialisation
je pense que ça sera des sujets
évidemment intéressants aussi bon on
s'est mis dans le dans le dans le dans
ce travail évidemment toutes les régions
se sont organisées et organisées une
concertation pour travailler d'abord
cette territorialisation et puis dans un
second temps le parcours vers le zanne
on sait très vite retrouver confrontés à
un certain nombre d'interrogations qui
ont été portés et par région de France
Carole Delga et par les présidents de
région qui ont pris l'initiative
d'écrire soit à madame la Première
ministre soit à Christophe Béchu en
relevant et en demandant un certain
nombre de sujets le desserrement du
calendrier assurément ou en tout cas on
a fait des propositions évidemment dans
ce sens la question des grands projets
parce que ça nous semble extrêmement
inéquitable de ce point de vue là et
tout dépend du parcours et de contexte
des régions évidemment et puis ce sujet
que l'on partage il y a eu un recours de
l'AMF sur les décrets sur le la question
de du FA des règles ou de facils des
objectifs et c'est également une
situation que l'on que l'on partage on a
pu
faire passer ce mot ces évolutions là il
est vrai que depuis le mois d'octobre et
Christophe Béchu avait nous avait
concerté début octobre en disant que
très vite il allait demander une
réécriture des décrets d'applications à
tout le monde mais sans changer le cadre
de la loi et sans changer le délai de
février 2024 donc c'est pour ça que la
proposition peut peut-être venir un peu
ouvrir des perspectives et c'est une
bonne et c'est une bonne idée mais force
est de constater que depuis nous n'avons
pas d'informations concrètes pas non
plus sur le sur le délai et que les
courriers sont restés plutôt sans
réponse ce qui nous pose souci et
question et théoriquement si on doit
dans le rétroplanning de février 2024
avancé on devrait là toutes les régions
voter en mars avril
la proposition de modification des sera
dettes
pour ensuite avoir tout le tout le temps
pour être à temps sur en février 2024
donc évidemment on est dans une
situation de blocage et au-delà de ce
sujet de de timing de calendrier et
d'incertitude sur l'écriture ou la
réécriture des décrets d'applications on
a aussi fait remonter par le fruit de la
concertation vraiment parce que je pense
en effet et vous l'avez dit personne
d'autre que les régions
n'est plus au fait de ce qu'est la
construction d'un stradettes on les
avait tous fait
on doit recommencer
quelques mois ou un an ou un an et demi
plus tard je si il y a un sujet et j'en
reviendrai sur ma conclusion là-dessus
c'est vraiment la nécessité de la
stabilité la stabilité des documents
d'aménagement de territoire la stabilité
des documents de planification être sans
arrêt en train de refaire et de
retravailler ces sujets là c'est c'est
absolument pas raisonnable donc de ce
point de vue là effectivement on a un
certain nombre au delà du problème de
calendrier on a des problèmes d'impensé
de fond le rapport entre zan et
logements social le rapport entre zanes
et évolution du trait de côte ou loi
montagne en effet le rapport entre zanes
et capacité de renaturation dans les
communes rurales c'est aussi évidemment
un sujet de question et le rapport entre
zanes et énergie renouvelable donc ça
c'est aussi des sujets de fonds sur
lesquels on n'a pas de on n'a pas de
réponse
si j'en viens rapidement au à vos
articles et à vos à vos propositions il
y en a un certain nombre qui vont
recueillir un avis assez favorable de la
part des régions et qui vont de façon
convergente dans ce sens là sur la
demande de desserrement du calendrier
oui bien sûr c'est une c'est une bonne
chose en tenant compte parce que on est
en responsabilité sur ces sujets là il
est territoires nous attendent aussi un
certain nombre de territoires sont
actuellement en cours de révision ou des
élaboration de leur code de leur pluie
de leur plu eux sont inquiets du timing
aussi évidemment et du calendrier on a
cette écoute là en vers eux décalé d'un
an il faut le faire pour tout le monde
bien entendu ce que l'on vous
demanderait et ce que l'on fera valoir
c'est l'idée de ne pas décaler que sur
la partie foncière puisque la loi climat
résilience et la loi à Jacques nous
demande aussi des modifications bien
souvent des radettes sur d'autres volets
pour la nouvelle Aquitaine c'est le cas
pour la logistique et c'est le cas pour
les déchets et nous apparaîtrait curieux
de modifier la le stradette sur ses
volets là parce que le calendrier
n'aurait pas été modifié alors qu'on
aurait un an de plus pour le foncier on
ne peut pas comme je l'ai dit être sans
arrêt en train de refaire et real
élaborer des stradettes surtout que
c'est un coup pour les régions et c'est
en fonctionnement pour
donc mais sur le principe évidemment
c'est bien sur l'enveloppe nationale
c'est notre souhait et notre souhait
pour une enveloppe nationale c'est que
ça soit un compte à part le ministre
déchu parle d'un comté à part depuis le
début oui un comté à part mais nous on
voit un comté à part Oran enfin or
enveloppe blanche qui ne soit pas
rectualisé et redistribuer entre les
régions partant du principe aussi qu'on
n'a pas le même contexte dans le travail
d'élaboration des seradettes les régions
on a fait ce travail en tenant compte
des parcours et des trajectoires des
territoires et en différenciant
justement selon les territoires là la
loi ne vient pas différencier suivant
les régions suivant les parcours et les
situations des régions on n'a pas toutes
le même taux d'artificialisation on n'a
pas toutes les mêmes capacités de friche
de de voilà donc il faut aussi réfléchir
les choses donc cette et puis on n'a pas
tous les mêmes le même développement
évidemment je suis d'une région
concernée notamment par GPSO et par la
par la LGV à continuer donc il nous
apparaît très normal que ces grands
projets là remontent dans une enveloppe
nationale sans être mutualisée ensuite
et oui bien sûr pourquoi pas au-delà des
projets d'infrastructures faire monter
dans ces projets là des projets
industriels on doit réindustrialiser la
France il y a les giga Factory il y a
d'autres sujets en nouvelle-aquitaine on
propose dans la liste des grands projets
un projet de nature industrielle voilà
donc on connaît et dont on mesure déjà
l'impact on avait déjà proposé et
demander s'il était possible d'avoir une
enveloppe blanche pour le développement
économique et pour les grands projets
industriels il nous a été dit que non il
faut être en capacité de mesurer
l'impact au nombre d'un hectares des
grands projets qui remonteraient il y a
peut-être un sujet sur les différents
critères mais là pour le coup je vais
parler un nouvel Aquitaine c'est vrai
que certaines régions sont très grandes
c'est d'actualité en ce moment il se
trouve qu'en nouvelle-aquitaine
considérait qu'un un grand projet au
niveau national serait un projet
interrégional ça va par exemple nous
amener à pas pouvoir décompter au niveau
national la liaison Poitiers Limoges que
l'on considère comme étant d'intérêt
national mais qui est au sein de notre
région donc ça aussi c'est des sujets
sur lesquels il faudra probablement
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse discuter sur
la partie fascicule des objectifs ou des
ou des ou fascicules des règles ce que
l'on aimerait nous les régions c'est en
revenir à l'esprit de la loi notre qui
laissait la liberté aux régions pas
forcément pas on est d'accord pour que
ça soit pas obligatoirement dans le
fascicule des règles peu de régions ont
mis les 50% d'ailleurs dans le fascicule
des règles
pourquoi le rendre obligatoire
absolument dans le fascicule des
objectifs pourquoi ne pas laisser un peu
plus de latitude aux régions pour
décider entre objectifs et règles ça ça
peut faire partie des sujets juste
nouvelle Aquitaine par exemple on a mis
les 50% dans le fascicule des objectifs
donc on est sur la la prise en compte on
a mis quand même une règle une règle
générale qui parlait de la sobriété
foncière sur le sur le fait d'en tenir
compte et c'était négocié avec les
squats à l'époque
pardon de vous interrompre ce sera la
seule fois c'est un point très important
il est technique mais il est très très
important donc vous n'êtes pas en
demande Ta fascicule réglementaire dans
chaque sera d'être pas en demande au nom
de région de France de sera dette
normatif vous ne dites pas que le sens
de l'histoire concernant toutes les
politiques publiques logements logements
social et autres urbanisme aménagement
c'est d'avoir des régions chefs de fil
qui planifient qui planifie tous ces
sujets c'est bien ce que vous dites le
fascicule des objectifs il est quand
même normatif mais c'est juste le sujet
de la prison compte par rapport aux
annes
la prise en compte c'est bien ce que
vous dites c'est pas une mise en
compatibilité que vous prenez
nous on demande d'en revenir à l'esprit
de la loi notre qui nous laissait la
possibilité d'inscrire la sobriété
foncière soit dans les objectifs soit
dans les règles générales
voilà laissez le choix suivant le
contexte donc ça peut être ça peut être
prescriptif la nouvelle Aquitaine on a
mis 50 % en objectif et ça a été fait
exprès et ça a été le fruit de la
négociation avec les territoires et en
règle générale on a dit qu'il fallait
d'abord inciter et faire la
démonstration que les projets ne
pouvaient pas se tenir dans l'enveloppe
urbaine existante d'essayer voilà un
petit peu comme ça a été c'était surtout
sur le la question du commerce et du
commerce de périphérie de faire en sorte
sur ce sujet là de limiter l'extension
en commerce du commerce de périphérie et
de dire faut d'abord prouver que ça peut
pas trouver sa place dans l'enveloppe
urbaine existante ou en centre-ville ou
en centre bourg avant de pouvoir tout
simplement aller sur des terres des
terres nouvelles voilà et ça on l'a mis
dans les règles générales avec une
portée un petit peu plus prescriptive
donc il peut y avoir comme ça de la
finesse tout tout le principe c'est
celui de respecter la négociation et ça
avait été discuté et co-écrit avec avec
les scottes à l'époque parce que
n'existait pas encore la fameuse
conférence régionale d'escottes mais il
en a pas moins qu'on des réunies de
façon Haddock voilà et toutes les
régions ont fait ont fait de la même de
la même manière c'est évidemment pour
nous important la prise en compte des
efforts passés oui c'est c'est un
principe vertueux on y travaille c'est
pas facile dans les faits chaque
territoire considère qu'il a été
vertueux de son point de vue et de son
contexte donc de ce point de vue là ça
sera voilà il faut comment trouver une
méthode
là-dessus sur la prise en compte on y
travaille c'est c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué si on regarde la consommation
pure vous avez une une géographie qui
ressort et on voit très nettement les
hectares consommés par par EPCI ou par
ou par Scott ou par département si vous
rapportez la même mesure par habitant
supplémentaire l'image est inversée bien
souvent les territoires plus ruraux ou
les territoires moins attractifs ont
consommé beaucoup plus d'hectares par
habitant supplémentaire donc on essaie
de travailler différemment en regardant
également la consommation sur les
dernières années et on distinguant on
essaie distinguer 2011 2016-2021 pour
voir quel a été l'effort et on essaie de
mesurer ça voilà mais c'est complexe
quoi qu'il en soit la mesure des efforts
passés il y a beaucoup de pédagogie
aussi à faire là-dessus parce que
évidemment les scottes voient et on a
dans notre stradette actuelle notamment
cette notion de trajectoire c'est-à-dire
un Scott qui est à 30%
qu'il arrive à 45 il fait déjà un gros
effort après tout
bon voilà mais il faut il faut
évidemment y faire attention et puis
ensuite il y a les dispositions
que vous avez citées sur lesquelles on
est plus on évidemment peut mesurer la
conférence régionale pour le pour le
zanne alors je reprendrai pas les propos
du ministre mais c'est vrai que du côté
de région de France on considère pour
nous que c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de souhaitable on a déjà
l'habitude de travailler avec la
Conférence régionale des scottes qui
d'ailleurs intègrent les EPCI on a tous
créé des commissions de concertation
Haddock on a la CTAP qui est un lieu
dans lequel toutes les étapes du sera
d'être sont discutées et sont présentées
en nouvelle-aquitaine on a créé un
groupe de travail
issu des membres de la CPAP ajoutant les
représentants des associations
départementales des maires roues sur
lesquels on travaille et on leur montre
et ce sont les personnes en nouvelle
Aquitaine les plus à jour de ce que l'on
travaille sur le sur le sur le sur le
stradette et sur le zan voilà une
conférence régionale zan qui viendrait
obliger la région à rendre
systématiquement des comptes sur toutes
les décisions ça nous apparaît compliqué
à mettre en œuvre ça va relancer
systématiquement des débats compliqués
il y a beaucoup de pédagogie à faire on
l'a fait les régions on a pris nos
responsabilités de ce point de vue là
tout le monde a créé ces temps de
concertation de discussion et de et de
dialogue cette conférence là telle
qu'elle est proposée nous apparaît
difficile à mettre en oeuvre difficile à
faire vivre et voir même ne pas
respecter pour le coup le chef de fila
de la région en matière d'aménagement du
territoire donc oui elle ouvriers
qui permettrait une gouvernance partagée
avec des collectivités si je peux me
permettre vous avez votre organisation
régionale mais vous le savez enfin voilà
toutes les régions ne fonctionnent pas
de la même manière et surtout c'est lié
à la prescriptivité qui évolue
aujourd'hui dans les décrets
alors franchement je connais pas une
région qui est actuellement fait son
sens radette et son âne sans discuter
avec avec les ceux qui sont au cœur de
la planification c'est-à-dire les
représentants des scottes et les mers et
puis on a beaucoup de courrier on a
beaucoup de remontées au-delà des
concertations qu'on fait sincèrement on
tient vraiment compte de ce qui est de
ce qui est tenu non pour nous la
Conférence régionale des scottes
intégrant les EPCI sans Scott la CTAP et
les commissions Haddock que l'on a pu
monter pour nous suffisent une une
conférence régionale d'usane très
sincèrement c'est c'est un sujet où dès
que vous rassemblez
et je vous parlerai de la proposition
des propositions des conférences des
scottes ils ont déjà eu beaucoup de mal
à se mettre d'accord entre eux parce que
chacun finalement
défend et c'est bien normal son propre
parcours son propre territoire son
propre contexte sa propre sa propre
situation un nouvel Aquitaine la
conférence régionale d'escouade n'a pas
fait de disposition de pourcentage de
territorialisation parce que c'était
impossible pour eux de se mettre
d'accord et donc à un moment en effet
c'est l'apport de la région de cette
devoir cette vision un peu supra et de
faire des propositions qu'ensuite on
discute et qu'on et qu'on conserve donc
pour nous cette conférence régionale
d'usane elle nous apparaît elle nous
apparaîtra vraiment difficile à mettre
en œuvre et probablement sur abonder à
des dispositifs qui existent et à un
moment on a le chef de fila en
aménagement du territoire c'est quand
même un peu respecter les compétences
des régions de les laisser s'organiser
organiser la concertation là-dessus et
bon dans le détail mais on verra on va
on réfléchit évidemment à ce qu'on
pourra vous écrire là-dessus parce que
il s'agit pas de balayer la possibilité
de de voilà de discuter de concerter et
d'expliciter les décisions mais si je
reprends les les articles il y a
vraiment des sujets sur lesquels les
régions vont être très très mise d'abord
la composition il faudrait quand même
effectivement en discuter
le pouvoir les pouvoirs qui sont qui
seraient donnés à cette conférence si on
doit systématiquement par délibération
en assemblée plénière justifier par
exemple de toutes les décisions que l'on
aurait à prendre sur une demande d'un
EPCI de faire rentrer un projet ou pas
dans une enveloppe régionale ou quoi
sincèrement ça nous apparaît assez
difficile à mettre en oeuvre et tout le
monde va demander son projet je ne fais
pas un rendez-vous avec un président de
PCI qui n'a pas son propre projet ou ses
deux trois projets à faire remonter dont
il considère et c'est normal de son
point de vue qu'il est d'un intérêt
primordial et d'un intérêt supérieur si
on fait ça si on fait ça la difficulté
va être celle de la mise en oeuvre de la
sobriété foncière et de l'objectif final
de des 50% territorialisés je crains en
2031 quand on y arrivera qu'on n'y
arrive pas si je coupe avec le sujet de
la garantie rurale voyez que ça renforce
ce côté
un peu échappatoire à l'objectif général
ça nous a paraît compliqué de d'entrer
dans ces dispositifs là mais on voulait
créera de façon plus précise aussi
j'ai bien entendu votre votre question
là-dessus
la garantie rurale bon
de la même façon les régions on tient
compte parce qu'on a bien compris encore
une fois il y a deux sujets le sujet de
la consommation le sujet du zan les mers
euros ont à juste titre porté l'idée
qu'il fallait raisonner par projet
plutôt que projet que raisonné par par
des comptes voilà que c'était pas ça et
franchement on est assez d'accord avec
ce avec ce sujet là et c'est important
et je comprends très bien et on comprend
très bien les maires roux qui disent
mais avec Lausanne on n'aura rien à
renaturer c'est inéquitable c'est vrai
c'est vrai un territoire qui aura des
facilités à renaturer évidemment pourra
réouvrir des droits à consommer donc
effectivement il faut réfléchir là
dessus en nouvelle-aquitaine par exemple
mais d'autres régions le font ont
réfléchi à puisqu'on doit
territorialiser faire en sorte que les
communes rurales ou les secteurs ruraux
les secteurs qui ne sont pas en profil
d'hyper attractivité ou qui n'ont pas
été très consommateurs du foncier puisse
disposer d'un pourcentage plus favorable
le premier sujet que l'on a ce que l'on
a vu par rapport à la Conférence
régionale des scottes et par les
propositions que l'on a eu un on s'est
mis d'accord sur l'échelle de
territorialisation ça on a discuté avec
les scottes et on sera à l'échelle des
squats par exemple en nouvelle-aquitaine
on n'avait pensé aux EPCI sans Scott on
s'était dit on va les regrouper
peut-être à l'échelle de nos contrats
territoires ou quoi on a vu que
finalement on n'avait pas le pouvoir et
on n'a pas finalement les régions a
décidé que des EPCI vont devoir se
regrouper entre eux ils ont pas fait de
Scott c'est en général pas par hasard et
les forcer à se regrouper entre eux pour
décider nous on considérait que d'être à
une échelle plus large ça permet d'être
plus intelligent ensemble sur
l'aménagement mais en tout cas si c'est
pas leur choix donc pour les EPCI sans
Scott on sera à l'échelle des EPCI ça
c'est vu avec l'échelle avec les avec
les scottes ce qui est vu aussi en
commun avec les scottes c'est le fait
que on parle plutôt en pourcentage
plutôt que de parler en hectares voilà
parce que bah ça laisse plus de
souplesse évidemment dans la question
dans le principe des trajectoires donc
on ne va pas fixer des hectares à
consommer et des enveloppes d'hectares
consommer on va donner des pourcentages
par profil
alors c'est la territorialisation des
50%. si on était à 50% sans projet
d'envergure national ou régional c'est
50%, ça veut dire certains territoires
sont à 52 d'autres à 48 en fonction de
leur profil de leurs besoins ça peut
être du 53-47 tout dépend tout dépend
c'est ça la territorialisation c'est ne
pas fixer 50 % à tout le monde parce que
sinon nous on a mis 50 % toutes les
régions ont mis 50% à peu près donc la
territorialisation c'est ça la
difficulté et c'est pour ça qu'on a
beaucoup milité pour l'enveloppe
nationale c'est que en
nouvelle-aquitaine par exemple c'est pas
50% qu'on doit qui va servir des tirages
c'est 54% parce qu'on va devoir
mutualiser 3500 hectares que l'on sait
en prévisionnel de grands projets ça
veut dire que les 50% ils sont à 54 et
de là si ça ne change pas mais on espère
que ça va changer de là et bien il va
falloir territorialiser donc on a fait
cinq profils
au fil littoral et rétro littoral pour
film métropolitain profil des grandes
aires urbaines profil en confortement
profil en revitalisation et à chacun on
va donner un pourcentage à l'échelle du
Scott ou à l'échelle de l'EPCI sans
Scott si on est en profil en
revitalisation ça sera peut-être du 51%
par rapport à 54 et en profil littoral
ça sera peut-être du 58 bon on travaille
ça et ça vraiment le travail en
discussion avec les territoires on
fournit toutes les tous les toutes les
calculs pour nous l'important c'est pas
partir de 54 c'est bien de partir de 50
c'est à dire de bien faire remonter
cette enveloppe des projets nationaux
pour pas grever la possibilité de
développement des territoires au niveau
local mais c'est ça que ça veut dire la
territorialisation et c'est ça qui est
au final dommage dans ce disque positif
de la loi climat-résilien c'est que la
sobriété foncière c'est vertueux ça
permet de travailler différemment
l'aménagement du territoire bien sûr
qu'on a eu des pratiques qu'il faut
repenser ça a été le cas sur le commerce
de périphérie et tout le monde s'en est
rendu compte maintenant mais
territorialisé ou aller vers Lausanne ça
devient plus compliqué sa crise et la
vertu se perd un peu se perd un peu en
chemin évidemment et surtout le grand
défaut c'est que ça pousse tout le monde
à travailler sur du quantitatif là où on
matière d'aménagement du territoire et
de sobriété foncière on devrait
travailler sur le qualitatif et donc
dans cette proposition de loi la
question du qualitatif elle doit être
vraiment un fil rouge un fil directeur à
notre sens parce que c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut et c'est là-dessus qu'on se
retrouve avec les grandes associations
AMF à MF département interco c'est
travailler sur le projet sur le
qualitatif sur l'aménagement autrement
voilà tout le monde peut pas densifier
de la même façon oui il faut changer les
formes urbaines mais ça demande du temps
c'est tous ces sujets là qui sont un peu
impensés et le fait de nous contraindre
là être sur des quantitatives dans un
délai extrêmement restreint et d'engager
tout le monde dans des modifications ça
devient un peu malheureusement
contre-productif à un objectif que que
tous les élus au contraire
intégrés donc bon sur cette garantie
rurale à voir c'est vrai que du coup si
elle fixe un hectare en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il faut bien
mesurer ce qui est du ressort d'être à
dettes et ce qui n'est pas voilà on
n'est pas du ressort du sera d'être de
descendre à la commune c'est ni notre
volonté ni notre objectif ni notre
savoir-faire très très concrètement donc
il faudra trouver des modalités
d'organisation nous en
nouvelle-aquitaine la garantie rurale on
l'a assuré à travers le profil Rev
organisation est confortement voilà par
exemple il y a des solutions il y a des
il y a des intelligences qui sont
possibles sur
pourcentage c'est un pourcentage voilà
sur la territorialisation bah je sais
pas encore je sais que le jour où je
serai dire ce qui sera décompter de en
grand projet voilà sachant qu'on veut
aussi conserver un enveloppe des grands
projets régionaux c'est important parce
que tout n'a pas vocation à remonter au
niveau national on est d'accord il faut
garder cette capacité de mutualisation
il y a plein de dispositifs intelligents
sur lesquels on peut réfléchir à travers
ces sera d'être c'est plutôt de cette
façon qu'on voit les choses la question
de la fongibilité vous parlez des des
projets territoriaux c'est très
intéressant comme dispositif bien sûr
pourquoi pas
j'ai vu dans votre proposition de loi
que il serait considéré que les les
grands projets les projets territoriaux
pour les EPCI et les communes sans squat
ou sans plu pour être peut-être décidé
par les stadettes à notre avis non on
n'a pas à nous les régions à s'occuper
de ça c'est pas forcément la modalité
pour le coup on est vraiment dans le
local là où il y a des scottes il
décideraient de leur de leur trajectoire
et ce sens-côte pourrait pas ça serait
la région qui déciderait ça ça nous
apparaît un peu ça paraîtra difficile ça
pour le coup s'il y a une conférence
régionale d'usane je peux vous garantir
que ça ça posera ça posera discussion
évidemment donc on peut trouver plein de
sujets sur le logement social sur le
logement social pourquoi pas prévoir une
décote pourquoi ne pas prévoir une
décote pour le logement social sur la
consommation foncière il y a plein
d'idées il y a plein de choses comme ça
simplement effectivement dès qu'on est
dans le quantitatif et qu'on fixe comme
ça des choses très précises ça devient
plus compliqué à mettre en oeuvre et
surtout bien réfléchir à ce qui est de
niveau d'une région et ce qui n'est pas
du niveau et des compétences d'une
région là dessus
voilà alors la saisine voilà bon
l'article 5 sur la saisine des EPCI
après avis de la conférence zan sur les
projets d'ampleur régional ça nous
paraît vraiment impossible à mettre en
place enfin ça là-dessus pour nous ça
nous paraît pas souhaitable et
acceptable
et puis et puis voilà bon après je peux
répondre à toutes vos questions il y a
la question de la Desjardins aussi des
espaces verts de la densification du
calcul de la consommation
l'artificialisation il y a plein de
sujets sur lesquels on vous répondra
aussi évidemment par écrit là-dessus
merci beaucoup pour cette exclusivité
extrêmement complet et éclairant
position de la de la RF et aussi teinté
de votre expérience évidemment sans plus
attendre je rends la parole tout de
suite à notre rapporteur qui a une ou
deux questions à vous poser et derrière
madame cuckermen et si vous pouviez
prendre votre tour c'est les uns les
autres si vous avez des questions à
poser
mais quand je commence à prendre le tour
je vais intervenir rapidement et laisser
plutôt la parole à mes collègues mais
réagir sur une chose déjà donc merci
parce que c'est très riche comme comme
intervention m'ont proposé donc vraiment
merci infiniment nous aider ma question
est la suivante en fait le
piné tout le long et puis je suis plus
d'accord sur la conférence régionale et
votre réaction c'est bien ça c'est bien
ça ma problème à ce stade je vais vous
le dire autrement je suis maire Graal
d'une mère d'une petite commune je ne
suis pas arrivé à me faire entendre de
le PCI du Scott encore moins de la
région ça arrive je me sens pas concerné
par Lausanne je subisan j'ai
l'impression que c'est un truc de riche
un truc de métropole voilà et pour
autant c'est un objectif que que je
partage parce que je suis pas idiot j'ai
compris que l'air du temps me le demande
ou autre aux normes fait des gros yeux
si je suis conscient de l'urgence
climatique voilà admettons voilà voilà
par ailleurs
non mais quel que soit les les bancs on
a voté la territorialisation qui veut
dire en droit de proposition exercée par
les squats avant le 22 octobre dernier
il faut être franc l'État n'a rien fait
pour que ça marche cette affaire parce
que ne voulait pas parce que ne pouvait
pas enfin il y a 1000 raisons de sorte
que sur votre table le 22 octobre il y a
pas grand chose et là on a deux types de
régions je le dis de manière très très
rapide et caricaturale parce que ça
j'accélère il y a des régions qui sont
paras c'est sec
de fila la transition écologique et puis
il y en a même que certaines qui veulent
créer une agence régionale etc et savoir
même à la commune près ce qui va ce qui
va se passer sur l'artificialisation
pour décider à la commune près je
caricature voilà mais à celle qui va
veulent pas s'embarrasser parce que en
réalité droit de proposition veut dire
demande de différenciation et après vous
vous avez à dire toi oui toi non toi
plus toi moins et vous ne vous le pas
vous régions de France sauf à avoir une
vision d'ensemble voilà
voilà alors donc là notre
territorialisation mastan échec ce qui
fait que la colère est intacte quelle
que soit des bancs et ça devient une
mission conjointe de contrôle qui
devient qui dépose une proposition de
loi et cette commission spéciale
aujourd'hui
où on a plusieurs
réponses à apporter notamment 2
qu'est-ce qu'on dit ces mères ruraux à
ces petites communes de littoral de la
montagne à chaque fois j'oublie pas
voilà qui n'ont pas réussi à se faire
entendre on propose deux filets de
sécurité pourquoi ce droit universel ce
droit universel parce qu'on veut pas
opposer l'urbain et le rural parce qu'il
est alors universel comme son nom le
propose on constate déjà sur le terrain
que ça rassure beaucoup d'élus
d'entendre parler de cet hectare là
alors qu'il n'est pas un hectare open
bar qui sortirait du zan c'est dans le
cadre des procédures évidemment
d'urbanisme mais rassure déjà alors le
ministre nous parle du droit au 1% on en
sait toujours pas plus sur ce 1% ce qui
est ce qu'il implique et qui sort
gagnant de cette affaire voilà mais
c'est pour ça et la part réserver
ruralité c'est un peu ça aussi c'est
pour donner un deuxième motif à nos élus
de se rassurer et d'aller dans Lausanne
quoi comme on disait la gouvernance
c'est quoi la gouvernance c'est parce
qu'on a l'impression depuis le début que
comment dire je vais rester
on a quelques hauts fonctionnaires qui
définissent en accord avec eux-mêmes de
manière unilatérale un petit peu
arbitraire ce qui est un projet
d'intérêt national outre que entre-temps
on a des décrets qui reviennent sur tout
ce qu'on a voté et que non seulement on
sait pas ce que c'est qu'un projet
d'intérêt national mais ça ne sort pas
vraiment
du décompte enfin ce n'est pas décompter
c'est pas compté à part voilà
outre que le fait que les décrire
reviennent sur quasiment tout ce qu'on a
voté voilà mais voilà les projets
d'intérêt national on s'est dit quand
même pas mauvais de demander aux élus ce
qu'ils en pensent voilà alors je sais
bien que on en a marre des ctaper on en
a marre de tous ces dispositifs sont
lourd à gérer qui existent déjà alors
cela dit vous dites c'est intéressant de
repos vous dit ça marche alors c'est la
première fois que j'entends ça que
c'était la paix ça marche que nos
conférence et Scott ça marche merci de
ne rien rajouter bistrot que les élus
hyper ruraux que nous avons là et bien
ils ont toujours l'impression que leurs
élus les plus ruraux dans leur
département et ben n'arrivent pas à se
faire entendre dans une conférence des
Scott n'arrive pas à faire valoir leur
spécificité notre haute question c'est
ça c'est comment faire en sorte que
puisse malgré tout donner un avis sur
qu'est-ce qu'un projet d'intérêt
national qu'est-ce qu'un projet
d'intérêt régional et puis cette
gouvernance Duane au quotidien alors
qu'il serait un quotidien annuel un
rendez-vous annuel je renature est-ce
que je peux est-ce que je peux récupérer
des droits est-ce que j'en ai pas besoin
de tous ces droits à ce que je peux les
transférer un peu de souplesse dans ce
truc alors voilà alors d'où la question
récurrente de la présidente si c'est pas
ça qui marche
quelquefois de gouvernance on peut on
peut imaginer vous voyez mais c'est mais
c'est c'est un peu ça sous le souci de
la gouvernance c'est des questions que
nous posons vous voyez donc en fait ma
question c'est ça c'est est-ce que
est-ce que parce que je pourrais faire
aussi une petite sortie sur la
concertation parler de la concertation
des scottes et des pluies et des plu
mais une concertation d'un sera dette
moi j'ai des remontées dans ma région
alors voilà on fait des ateliers les
maires vont coller vont coller un
post-it contre un mur pour dire ce
qu'ils veulent voilà et au bout de deux
heures en fin voilà il m'est même arrivé
de voir une vice-présidente avoir sur
son ordinateur ce que un powerpoint
c'était en novembre du mois de février
elle savait déjà ce qu'elle allait dire
en février donc en réalité pas vraiment
de discussion autour des propositions
les rares qui ont été déposées vous
voyez j'ai un peu véhément mais c'est
pour aller vite mais c'est pour vous
faire réagir parce que c'est un propos
évidemment très intéressant que proposer
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
la le changement de nature du sera net
qui devient prescriptif si effectivement
le gouvernement va au bout justifie
aussi l'attente forte des niveaux de
collectivité infra qui se disent mais
moi où je me manifeste où j'exprime mes
priorités mes propositions si demain un
caractère prescriptif se pose au
stradette et que de fait ce sera demain
le contenu de mes documents d'urbanisme
et donc il est clair qu'aujourd'hui il y
a une vraie revendication des élus de
par le changement de nature
mais c'était déjà prescriptif
ça allait plus avec l'obligation dans le
fascicule des règles générales non mais
non mais ça allait plus dans le du fait
de l'inscription obligatoire dans le
fascicule des règles général ce qu'on ne
demande pas il y a pas de souci nous on
demande d'en revenir à la loi notre
c'est-à-dire voilà ah ben c'est bien de
changer c'est pour ça que pour nous
c'est une un dispositif avec lequel on
est d'accord simplement par rapport à la
proposition là si j'ai bien lu la
proposition de loi c'est de dire ça sera
obligatoirement dans le fascicule des
objectifs donc dans le simple niveau de
prise en compte nous on proposerait
peut-être d'en revenir à la loi note
c'est-à-dire de laisser la liberté aux
régions de travailler un peu en finesse
aussi les règles générales sur la
sobriété foncière si elle le souhaite
voilà tout simplement mais bon après
c'est pas mais que ça ne soit pas dans
le fascicule des règles général enfin
c'est convergent là-dessus et et on a en
plus très bien compris le recours de la
MF puisque c'est venu par décret
d'application donc pas de souci
là-dessus on est convergent
sur sur la conférence régionale notre
seul sujet c'est d'être opérationnel
c'est-à-dire bon j'ai bien vu on
regardera et on fera des propositions
aussi sur la composition et sur le et
sur la nature des
de ce qui peut être proposé et des
pouvoirs et des prérogatifs donnés
simplement là où on vous a l'air c'est
de dire
faisable si j'en parle
tous les VP aménagements de territoire
de toutes les régions serait dans la
même situation que moi et les présidents
de région qui sont vraiment qui peuvent
pas faire un rendez-vous avec un élu
depuis un an sans qu'on leur parle du
zan très franchement tout le monde est
assez au fait des choses donc la
concertation c'est plutôt notre intérêt
de la faire les régions c'est ça que je
veux vous faire entendre bien sûr
certaines régions se sont plus ou moins
engagées dans la sobriété foncière ont
testé et tout mais au final on sait tous
retrouver de façon assez assez
convergente et on fait beaucoup de
benchmarking simplement on fait en même
temps donc on a un groupe de travail
sera net un région de France on fait
beaucoup de benchmarking les présidents
on parle en
assemblée de région de France pour voir
où ils en sont ce qu'ils font et la
situation dans laquelle on est on est à
peu près tous je peux vous citer j'ai la
liste et on a fait le travail avec les
équipes j'ai la liste de où en sont
toutes les régions exactement sur la
situation de blocage actuel à peu près
il y en a qu'une ou deux qui continuent
à avancer un peu dans le dans le
calendrier donc on partage quand même un
peu la méthode
simplement vous aurez pas réglé le sujet
de la représentation de de chaque mer
rurale parce que dans une conférence
régionale des scottes il sera représenté
par dix mères ruraux voilà ce problème
de comment faire redescendre en
granularité en finesse la pédagogie de
ces sujets-là je ne pense pas que cette
conférence régionale du Zen il répondra
à 100% ça ça m'étonnerait vous aurez
toujours des des mères qui découvriront
un peu voilà et encore une fois le fait
de travailler par profil et il y a plein
de choses dans cette proposition de loi
qui nous apparaissent très intéressantes
ce que vous proposez sur les communes
littorales et sur le ou sur les communes
de montagne c'est à dire de tenir compte
déjà des injonctions qu'elles ont c'est
c'est évidemment très intéressant moi je
j'y suis favorable est-ce qu'il faut
cumuler le sujet c'est de pas perdre de
vue quand même un objectif global de
sobriété foncière est-ce qu'il faut
cumuler le fait de rendre en
renaturation
ce qui pas été ce qui aura été
finalement démoli ou abandonné du fait
de l'évolution de trait de côte plus ne
pas décompter en consommation foncière
ce qui sera construit de nouveau je sais
pas s'il faut cumuler les deux
sincèrement mais bon votre proposition
elle a au moins le l'avantage de nous
faire nous interroger là-dessus mais en
tout cas comptez ça de façon différente
oui pour le pour la montagne c'est et
pour la loi montagne c'est pareil il y a
plein de sujets sur lesquels c'est
intéressant de de faire avancer les
choses et si la loi change parce que le
sujet les discussions qu'on avait avec
le ministre et qui nous a dit qu'il
changerait pas la loi ce qui voulait
réécrire c'est les décrets d'application
donc si la loi change à travers cette
proposition tant mieux ça vous permet de
proposer des dispositifs qui vont être
de nature à rassurer les élus et je suis
pas sûr que la conférence tout
simplement parce que là il y aura il y
aura des choses écrites que les
stradettes devront respecter et nous on
respecte la loi donc que l'estradettes
devront respecter la conférence
régionale d'usane encore une fois avec
ses pouvoirs et nous demandons il y a
des conseils régionaux aussi parmi nous
de délibérer systématiquement on
justifiant de pourquoi on n'a pas tenu
compte de tel projet ou de tels je vais
pas dire usiane nagas mais la foire
d'empoigne on va la connaître et la
façon dont chacun va regarder le voisin
et comment nous régions on va justifier
que là on va en tenir compte et là on va
pas en tenir compte franchement ça va
être très compliqué à objectiver le
sujet dans sera dette c'est qu'on doit
être dans de l'objectivation voilà et si
on va dans des particularismes et qu'il
faut qu'on justifie par des libérations
systématiquement de tous les
particularismes ou de notre refus des
particularismes je crains que ça soit
compliqué et je crains aussi
juridiquement que que ça soit assez
assez instable voilà c'est juste ça si
cette conférence va exister pour nous et
c'est tapé si quand même on les réunit
voilà bon quoi qu'il en soit c'est même
une obligation alors peut-être que
toutes les régions n'ont pas exactement
les mêmes pratiques et après sur les
sujets de garantir rurale de décompte et
tout ça il faut regarder les choses en
nouvelle-aquitaine on a plus de Frédéric
Christian définition
NC je pense qu'on a 4100 ou communes
4100 communes qui sont en ruralité
critères Insee en nouvelle-aquitaine ça
fait 4100 hectares
plus les 3005 des grands projets sachant
que sur notre rapport de consommation
foncière passée on était à 46 000 on
divise par deux c'est 23000 23000 vous
enlevez les 4000 vous enlevez les 3000
la remutualisation le pourcentage il va
il va se complexifier après franchement
voilà pourquoi pas ça s'étudie ça se
regarde mais bon
en tout cas ça c'est à l'échelle locale
que ça doit se travailler c'est
certainement pas austrade de justifier
ou de travailler ces sujets là pour les
communes non c'est pas notre c'est pas
notre objet c'est pas notre notre
demande
pour qu'il puisse poser la question à
commencer par Madame ku Karman oui merci
Madame la vice-présidente qui
représentait aujourd'hui région de
France tout d'abord effectivement et je
peux le comprendre que région de France
finalement dans vos propos ne souhaite
pas être les arbitres d'une noix qui qui
n'est pas la leur
à partir de là on a deux postulats
peut-être un troisième et le premier ce
serait pour région de France de devenir
finalement assez révolutionnaire et
d'être dans le camp de ceux qui qui
dénoncent cette loi et qui appelle de
leurs vœux à la rédaction d'une nouvelle
loi et avec beaucoup de respect pour
être aussi régional depuis 2004 je n'ai
jamais vu cette orientation là prise par
région de France la deuxième et
finalement mais comme vous l'avez très
bien dit celle de respecter la loi et
donc
de venir dans le débat qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui compris par rapport à la
proposition de loi du Sénat est-ce que
oui ou non les régions dans leur
diversité des grandes régions des
petites régions des régions qui sont
très fortement incarnées par un
président ou une présidente d'ailleurs
plus que tout autre orientation
politique d'autres régions qui sont
peut-être moins mises en évidence sur le
devant de la scène du jeu politique
national vont devoir demain arbitrer sur
une forme de territorialisation locale
et on sent bien que pour le coup et
c'est un point commun à tous les
présidents de région aujourd'hui
personne n'en veut trop de peur de se
fâcher d'ailleurs avec ses propres
territoires qui lui ont permis dans la
diversité mais avec une forme
d'unanimisme dans les différentes
régions en tout cas de la métropole
d'être brillamment réélu lors du dernier
scrutin et je vous le dis très
tranquillement moi j'ai fait partie de
ceux qui ont dit que les grandes régions
ça allait devenir des grandes Baronnies
et que même si vous avez défendu la loi
autres et ce fameux stranet on crée déjà
à l'époque des usines à gaz qui de faite
n'allaient pas accélérer la
décentralisation mais refaire des
concentral des concentrations régionales
parce que moi j'entends et je le
respecte et je je vous crois sincère
mais j'ai aujourd'hui un souci c'est que
tous les vices présidents de région en
charge de l'aménagement du territoire
nous disent à juste titre que tout se
passe bien chez eux qu'on a consulté
qu'on a travaillé et que tout va très
bien mais à part ça quand même madame la
marquise aucune aucun jugement à votre
propos il va falloir quand même qu'on se
dise les choses c'est que moi je suis
aussi issue d'une formation politique où
j'ai des élus en majorité ou en
opposition selon les régions et que tout
se disent ou me rapporte que en fait et
c'est et je crois que c'est quoi quand
je dis ça parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
preuve d'humilité tout c'est bien normal
tous disent ben c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça et que ce qui est
exposait le rapporteur tout à l'heure
c'est que le maire rural
qu'il ne demande pas de la compassion il
demande simplement à être bien à être
entendu et à être écouté ben ce maire
rural à un moment donné il a pas voix au
chapitre mais quand on dit semeur rural
c'est pas le maire de la commune de 300
habitants dont effectivement la France
pourrait peut-être se passer pour
continuer d'avancer demain c'est un
maire qui aujourd'hui gère un territoire
avec des habitants dans une
intercommunalité qui défend des projets
et qui aujourd'hui est encore plus
peut-être d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que
quand nous avons eu les débats sur la
loi notre et la fusion des régions qui
aujourd'hui est un maillot indispensable
de la République et qui se dit ben moi
quand j'ai envie de faire quelque chose
je peux pas parce que j'ai mon plu la
DDT elle m'a dit c'est pas possible j'ai
mon Scott quand ils sont dans un Scott
on m'a dit c'est pas possible j'ai alors
si en plus je suis dans d'autres zones
avec des PNR des trucs des machins c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible et le sera d'être il est
pas strictif il est pas prescriptif mais
quand même on m'a dit c'est pas possible
et ce quoi je vous le dis je voilà
caricature avec un peu d'ironie parce
qu'on est on est tous entre lui ici mais
en fait je crois que c'est ça et vous
voyez quand vous dites et je finirai sur
ça
que la conférence régionale sur le zan
elle est compliquée et je vous entends
parce que je vois je sais ce que ça veut
dire que la gestion
mais franchement faut qu'on se le dise
les CTP c'est pas vrai ça ne marche pas
ça marche super bien pour les présidents
de départ département pour les
présidents des grandes EPCI parce que
c'est cool on se retrouve et tout va
bien et on règle nos affaires entre nous
mais en vrai pour les élus au quotidien
ça ne marche pas et alors peut-être que
vous avez raison la proposition que nous
nous faisons c'est de faire une
conférence régionale d'usane ou un
moment donné on fait rentrer je termine
les élus les mers en tant que tel comme
étant des acteurs à part entière de
l'aménagement du territoire donc ça je
veux simplement vous entendiez parce que
je crois qu'on en a besoin et que moi
les qualitatifs les sobriétés ça ça
marche toujours pour les riches pour les
plus pauvres c'est toujours compliqué
c'est vrai chez les citoyens comme dans
les territoires et donc je crois que à
un moment donné le rôle de région de
France avec la compétence aménagement du
territoire qu'elle a voulu qu'elle a
réclamé au moment de la loi à l'autre et
bien ça devrait être justement d'être un
des acteurs et un des vecteurs d'un
aménagement du territoire qui part du
bail et qui va vers l'égalité des
territoires plutôt qui continue de les
aseptiser dans toutes les régions
quelles que soient les majorités
politiques merci Cécile j'ai encore
toute une série de demandes de paroles
on va les faire toutes comme ça vous
pour répondre et globalement si vous le
voulez bien alors Monsieur Vial Cédric
Vial on reste en Rhône-Alpes mais je
serais un peu moins enflammé que ma
collègue Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
merci madame la présidente Madame la
vice-président moi j'avais une question
plus terre à terre presque une question
pratique prendre un exemple pour revenir
sur la question des
des projets stratégiques nationaux ou
internationaux la nationaux régionaux
imaginez un département l'Isère ou le
président de la République viendrait sur
le département annoncé la création
un pôle technologique nouveau sur
certaines minatech qui créerait 1000
emplois à nouveau sur les nanotes sur la
technologie on pourrait considérer que
une annonce du président de la
République qui se déplace pour faire ça
mais l'emploi sur un secteur stratégique
ça devrait être considéré même si c'est
un investissement privé ça pourrait
considéré comme un intérêt d'envergure
national à ce niveau-là ça choquera
peut-être personne on peut considérer
qu'il y a une il faudra peut-être une
centaine d'hectares pour installer
l'entreprise et que du coup on mettra ça
sur une enveloppe sur une enveloppe
nationale spécifique toutefois imaginez
que c'est 1000 nouvelles personnes
ingénieurs
laborantin technicien n'habite pas
forcément sur le territoire qui est un
territoire rural
et donc il va falloir faire venir un
millier de familles
puisqu'il dans le couple il travaille
pas tous dans la même entreprise un
millier de famille
ces milliers de famille vont devoir vous
installer sur ce nouveau territoire dans
lequel on va installer cette entreprise
et donc sur les communes alentours ça
concerne environ 3 3 scottes s'il reste
admettons qu'elle arrête tous dans à 30
ou 40 km maximum de du site ça concerne
trois scottes de département
comment fait-on aujourd'hui
puisque les 100 hectares pour
l'entreprise on peut les prendre sur un
vote national mais les conséquences de
ce projet national et je pourrais vous
parler du lion Turin ou de la LGV qui
vous concerne les conséquences de ce
produit naturel qui sont pas dans une
enveloppe nationale comment on installe
ces 1000 logements sur des communes
rurales où on a des communes dans le
pélules auront le droit un permis de
construire
comment fait-on sans parler des
sous-traitants et des conséquences en
cascade donc c'est plus de 1000 en fait
qu'il faudrait parce que sinon si on les
installe et comprend sur le droit à
construire actuel il y a plus une il y a
plus un habitant de ces territoires qui
peut s'y installer donc comment fait-on
ou prend ton cette enveloppe spécifique
sachant que si on suit la règle si j'ai
bien compris le fonctionnement pour pour
donner des droits à construire nouveau à
ces communes dans les hors plu pour dire
il y a un projet d'Internet national à
côté on vous donne des droits construire
nouveau il faut modifier les scottes au
moins ces trois-là mais vu que c'est une
enveloppe fermée à l'échelle de la
région
il faudrait pour ça il faudrait modifier
le stradet et pour ça il faudrait
modifier d'autres Scots puisqu'il
faudrait enlever ces droits à construire
certains territoires pour pouvoir les
donner là donc la question c'est comment
fait-on parce que là on est en train on
a créé un système sur lequel tout le
monde se dit ça marche pas mais le
système nous empêche de le changer on
peut plus parce que s'il faut modifier
les uns dans la Loire pour pouvoir
baisser le droit construire la Loire
pour pouvoir l'augmenter en Isère et en
savoir vous imaginez très bien même si
on a une région qui est qui est très à
la manœuvre donc ma question est assez
simple comment envisagez-vous cela
est-ce que comment ça marche
merci chers collègues Sonia de la
pauvreté ensuite Christian Redon
sarrazzi et ensuite en gel
oui moi je voulais d'abord rebondir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit parce que
c'était l'objet aussi du parti de mon
intervention quand on installe ton lit
il y a besoin d'avoir une cité pour
abriter toutes les familles les
ingénieurs les gens qui travaillent sur
les chantiers sur la mise à niveau etc
etc et donc c'est un sujet en fait il y
a le projet même il y a le projet
lui-même et via toute la texture
l'infrastructure l'écosystème autour qui
va manger de fait du foncier et comment
comment cette enveloppe va être prise à
ce titre là au titre de l'économie qui
est quand même une des voilà une des
compétences majeures de la région la
logistique est un énorme sujet parce que
plus mangeur de fonciers que la
logistique ça n'existe pas ça n'existe
pas il y a de l'infrastructure routière
et il y a aussi énormément de fonciers
pour accueillir des grandes centrales
des
logistiques et intermodal et ça c'est un
vrai sujet puisque la dimension
logistique est intégrée dans les stades
désormais et pour le coup dans
l'enveloppe région il va falloir quand
même traiter cette question ou alors on
ne s'adapte pas à la modernité de la vie
et clairement la gestion logistique
c'est un des secrets aussi du
développement durable de bien gérer la
logistique et donc pour le coup dans
l'enveloppe ça va prendre beaucoup donc
comment vous avez pris en compte cette
question là et comment c'est pris en
compte au niveau de région de France je
vais revenir sur les la fameuse
conférence régionale et sur sur la ctape
il y a une quasi inanimité alors je sais
pas peut-être pas dans votre région sur
le fait de dire que les ctape sont des
chambres d'enregistrement et que
à juste titre vous vous parlez de faire
redescendre la pédagogie partout moi je
pense à juste également et je pense que
le Sénat est tout à fait d'accord avec
ça c'est qu'il faut faire remonter les
attentes de partout et ça ça peut être
aussi l'objet d'une d'une
conférence régionale et que certes une
conférence régionale de ça peut être une
foire d'emploi ou il y a des attentes
contradictoires mais après tout c'est
comme ça que s'exprime la démocratie
locale on peut le faire au niveau des
scottes pour qu'on ne pouvait pas le
faire au niveau régional je pense que si
chacun peut s'exprimer c'est au moins
une des garanties que ça chacun
s'approprie ces questions là et donc la
fameuse redescendre de pédagogie elle
peut se faire aussi dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire que la pédagogie elle se
fait par l'échange et par les sacrifices
que chacun consente au profit du
territoire d'un côté parce qu'ils
comprennent bien que le projet de
l'autre va être intéressant mais pour ça
il faut un lieu pour en échanger et pour
qu'ils en échange et l'échelle régionale
en ce qui concerne le ça ne me paraît
absolument essentiel ne serait-ce que
pour déterminer les projets d'envergure
régional départemental etc ma troisième
question porte sur le rôle des
départements comment voyez-vous les
départements la place qui vont qu'ils
occupent dans ce schéma puisque on a des
projets d'intérêt départemental et qui
des fois sont à cheval sur plusieurs
départements qui sont à la limite de
l'intérêt régional mais qui pour autant
sont des projet majeur pour lequel il
faut savoir
prioriser et puis sur le sur la
planification
qualitative que vous avez fort justement
mis en évidence je pense que le zan tel
que ça va être mis en place dans les
stradettes c'est vraiment la
planification Casio parce que les
contraintes de l'État vont être tels que
on ne va pas pouvoir faire autrement que
de la planification Casio et c'est la
négation de l'aménagement du terrain et
c'est l'année la négation de la
dimension démocratique et républicaine
de l'aménagement du territoire merci
beaucoup Sonia la parole est à Christian
Redon Sarrasi Christian rapidement sur
un sujet qui ici au Sénat dans les
territoires à et vient en numéro 1 c'est
la garantie rurale et en particulier des
précisions sur la notion de profil de
territoire comment sont déterminés par
qui
un peu plus de précision là parce que
c'est peut-être intéressant de d'avoir
cette approche là qui est une des
approches possible puisqu'on voit bien
que chaque jour on a même presque une
nouvelle
et savoir si c'est ces profils
permettent de faire assez de
différenciation territoriale dans la
répartition merci
Angèle Préville merci donc c'est la
matrice du Lot
donc c'est ce serait pour eux dire ce
qui a déjà été dit à savoir que les
efforts doivent être partagés et comment
justement on tient compte de cette chose
là et notamment puisque on est en train
de vivre et c'est le cas dans mon
département des situations nouvelles à
savoir pour les visites communales que
je que j'ai pu faire récemment il n'y a
plus rien à louer il n'y a plus rien à
vendre dans nos communes et pourtant il
y a des emplois à pourvoir donc comment
va-t-on faire quand on est dans une
commune rurale où il y a 250 habitants
ou déjà le PLU a fixé un demi hectare à
constructible dans les 10 ans à venir
pour cinq maisons donc là ça ne
correspond pas à ce qu'est notre profil
notamment dans le Lot et comment on
tient compte notamment de ce que nos
sociétés ne sont pas si rationnelles que
ça
et notamment sur les entreprises là où
elle s'installe elle choisissent parfois
des lieux qui leur plaisent ou parce que
les entrepreneurs veulent s'installer à
un endroit et que quelque part on est en
train de créer un carcan très qui va
peut-être handicapé notamment de
territoire ruraux également parce que
sur les grandes métropoles où on
accueille Bordeaux et Toulouse 20000
habitants de puces par an nous dans le
lot on est 160 14000 habitants on est
peu nombreux mais on a des possibilités
de développement et notamment parce
qu'on a beaucoup d'emplois pour voir et
on se rend compte que on va être pris
dans un de
dans un truc qui va vraiment nous
contraindre et peut-être pas nous
permettre le développement qu'on
pourrait avoir on a à Figeac on a un
développement important avec
l'aéronautique on a dans la ville où
j'habite un développement important on a
une usine internationale de confiture
les fameux petits pots Vichy là donc
voilà comment on fait et deuxième
question très
important pour moi sur ce qu'on appelle
la renaturation comment on va
comptabiliser parce que une friche qui
est une friche depuis déjà pas mal
d'années ben finalement la nature elle a
déjà repris ses droits et quelque part
dire qu'on va tout arracher ou tout
défaire alors que déjà il y a de la vie
qui s'est créé et qu'on peut pas le
comptabiliser comment va-t-on faire en
fait et comment vous vous voyez ce cette
problématique là avec peut-être un
marché qui va se créer sur l'achat de
ces choses là et donc voilà l'espèce
enfin voilà merci merci Angèle et on
pourra reposer la question au ministre
aussi parce que il pourra nous éclairer
là-dessus aussi il nous reste revendique
et puis après madame la vice-président
vous aurez généreusement quatre cinq
minutes on verra bien pour nous répondre
parce que le ministre arrive à 17h30
pour tout vous dire Madame la vie
ça va pas être le débat aujourd'hui
toute manière par rapport à ce que
devient de dire Angel la question c'est
l'intervention massive économique des
régions dans la politique du logement
demain qui est derrière Lausanne
nous avons essayé d'en parler un peu au
Sénat pour l'instant il y a des
frilosités ne serait-ce que sur les
établissements publics fonciers mais ce
qui est derrière Lausanne ça va être
obligatoirement une intervention très
forte des régions sur la question du
logement mais ça on va pas le trancher
aujourd'hui moi j'ai deux questions
assez précises on voit bien que sur la
part régionale toutes les intercos vont
essayer de démontrer que leur projet
économiques leurs projets
d'infrastructure et donc leur régional
donc vous allez passer votre temps ça
peut ce que vous avez déjà dit hâte de
voir arbitrer entre des demandes qui a
paieront toutes comme évidemment
légitime et si vous en choisissez un par
rapport à l'autre il y aura évidemment
une suspicion d'un choix politique
clientèle donc est-ce que vous préférez
pas qu'on vous donne une encore une fois
pour toute
une part de l'artificialisation
un nombre d'hectares et vous choisissez
à partir de là ce qui vous semble de
niveau régional plutôt que d'être dans
le coup par coup de remonter vers la
région les projets des uns et des autres
ce qui vous rendrait peut-être la vie
plus facile donc première question
deuxième question est-ce que région de
France est clairement opposée parce que
ça c'est un point important parce que le
risque qu'on a devant nous c'est quand
même qu'on est des enveloppes blanches
un peu partout et que on est 120 000
d'un côté sur les 50%, mais quand j'ai
30 min ici 30000 là et qu'on revienne
sur les 250 000 un peu de choses près
est-ce que vous êtes totalement opposé à
la mutualisation des projets d'intérêt
nationaux sur l'ensemble des régions
c'est-à-dire que pour rester au 50%
absolument ce que vous en avez débattu
ou pas et je m'arrêterai ces deux
questions techniques précises
je tente l'exercice d'abord il y a un
certain nombre de questions j'ai pas je
me les pose aussi
donc le monsieur le ministre sera là
n'hésitez pas on se les pose aussi on la
passe souhaité je le redire on venait de
finir notre dette bah oui
on a tenté puisque les régions ont des
parcours différents certains m'ont tenté
j'étais allé en PACA ils avaient
commencé à territorialiser par quatre
grandes zones ça c'est pas fait
Occitanie parler du Zéro
artificialisation nette je me souviens
d'une réunion
cités remarquable à Figeac ou la
vice-présidente à l'époque parlait du
zan ça c'est pas parce que dans la
concrétude et c'est ça sera finalement
ma conclusion et mon appel général c'est
à dire que dans ce qui sera écrit dans
cette proposition de loi au final et ce
qui ressortira il faut vraiment faire
attention parce que sur ce sujet là et
dans cette matière là le diable se niche
vraiment dans les dans les détails et il
y a des sujets qui sont très complexes
et quand on déroule la pelote on se
retrouve parfois en situation de blocage
ou de difficultés c'est pour ça que je
vous alerte sur la garantie rurale
franchement sur le principe c'est plutôt
ce sur quoi on va c'est à dire donner
des possibilités mais on vous on vous
écrira ça dans les dans les questions on
précisera j'ai bien compris vos sujets
mais attention attention à ces détails
là
pour moi oui enfin pour nous il doit y
avoir une enveloppe nationale sur les
infrastructures
ça c'est indispensable ça serait injuste
inéquitable ça serait indispens
d'ailleurs l'État ne différencie pas
entre les régions c'est déjà la première
fois de cette loi tout le monde est à
50% alors qu'on a pas les mêmes parcours
on n'a pas les mêmes projets
d'infrastructure des j'ai réalisé on n'a
pas les mêmes projets à réaliser encore
déjà ça c'est en premier sujet
il y a plein de sujets qu'on partage sur
lesquels on est en situation de blocage
je l'ai dit on a demandé si on pouvait
prévoir une enveloppe blanche pour les
projets de développement économique on
nous a répondu non voilà on nous a dit
les cabinets ministériens nous ont dit
ça ça sera pas possible et les juristes
nous en dit donc si vous trouvez des
critères qui nous aident plutôt que
d'avoir effectivement systématiquement
une interco qui va déposer une demande
qu'il faudra consulter la conférence
régionale d'usane et ensuite en
justifiant délibération on assemblée
plénière l'enveloppe blanche qu'est-ce
que l'enveloppe blanche c'est de dire
on connaît à peu près les grands projets
on sait ce que c'est une trajectoire
d'implantation de grandes industries ou
de grandes entreprises à l'échelle du
régime d'une région qu'est-ce on a créé
des dix dernières années passées
qu'est-ce qu'on va créer là et on va
dire je sais pas c'est 500 hectares ces
machins mais on sait pas encore dire
précisément quel projet
à blanc c'est-à-dire que là actuellement
la liste la loi nous demande il faut
savoir dire combien d'hectares vont être
dépensés c'est pour ça que nous par
exemple en nouvelle accritaine on a on a
mis le projet flying Wells on sait que
c'est 80 hectares donc on saura dire
c'est 80 hectares je sais pas si l'état
nous le validera mais en tout cas on va
essayer de le faire mais en tout cas
dire bah en nouvelle-aquitaine on sait
qu'on aura pour 500 hectares ou 700 ou
800 hectares à terme de projets de
développement économique il faudra
mutualiser on veut le mettre dans une
enveloppe régionale laissez-nous cette
liberté et comme ça on le décompte des
pourcentages
c'est bien c'est une marge mais une
marge à blanc essayez ces critères là
pourquoi pas
oui parce qu'au niveau de l'étage je
pense que ça fera trop aussi toutes les
régions font des comptes on peut tenter
hein on peut tenter
mais ça doit être dans une part
régionale qui ensuite est mutualisée
parce que
oui parce que pour le coup voilà pour le
coup il y a pas de raison que ça soit
grevé sur une commune en particulier ou
sur un territoire en particulier
là-dessus on partage la question de la
logistique elle peut être traitée mais
je sais pas si vous additionnez les
intercos mais ils vont vous le dire les
intercos le représentant des interco va
vous dire et je l'entends très bien ne
traitons pas la logistique type grand
plateforme
Amazon et la logistique nécessaire aux
industries pourquoi pas décompter faire
une décote sur la logistique des
industries propres propres à leur propre
à l'usine pas les plateformes Amazon et
tout ça ça il faut compter que vous
voyez deux niveaux de projet économique
un niveau qui devrait être dans le
compte national et un niveau qui
pourrait être mutualisé au niveau
régional d'infras qui sont
intermédiaires et qui justifierait
d'être mutualisé c'est ça votre idée
mais sans rentrer dans la justification
permanente de chaque interco à son
projet et va essayer de nous le faire
remonter on ne s'en sortira pas
non pour nous
non non
mais avec la garantie rurale à un
hectare c'est à peu près pareil donc
dans ce cas-là soyons dans une certaine
dans une certaine logique vous avez un
dispositif qui est très bien par exemple
c'est de compter la renaturation dès
maintenant
très bien très bien enfin tout ce qui
sera aidant tout ce qui
désenclavera cette situation qui est
contre-productive nous on le verra d'un
œil favorable évidemment
bah écoutez même la vice-présidente
merci beaucoup
pour cet échange extrêmement nourri et
intéressant nous vous souhaitons ainsi
qu'à tous les élus régionaux bon courage
et bonne chance pour mettre en oeuvre le
zéro artificialisation nette dans vos
territoires respectifs en tout cas
encore merci bon courage à vous et à
très bientôt merci à vous tous